أنا موظف في Apple وهذه
رسالة لأبل الآن
أنتظر بفارغ الصبر لمعرفة ما إذا كنت
سأطرد بسبب مقطع فيديو نشرته
قبل ثلاثة أيام
[موسيقى]
لذا
لا يمكنني معرفة [موسيقى]  أنت بالضبط كيف أعرف هذه
المعلومات ولكن يمكنني أن أخبرك أنه على
مدار السنوات الست الماضية كنت
مهندس أجهزة معتمدًا لشركة
معينة تحب التحدث كثيرًا عن الفاكهة
رقم واحد لا تقم بإزالة الجهاز
وإليك ما يحدث لقد فقدته
هاتفك بشكل صحيح ، لقد شق طريقه إلى الصين
كيف شق طريقه إلى الصين ليس
مهمًا ، لكن السبب الوحيد الذي يجعل هؤلاء
الأشخاص يتصلون بك الآن هو أن
هاتفك غير مفيد لهم بالفعل
وأنت الشخص الوحيد الذي يمكنه
إنقاذهم  وأقترح أنه ليس من
المضحك أنه بعد مراجعة
سياسات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، لا يوجد أي
ذكر لذلك على وجه التحديد في أي مكان
لا يقول فيه أنني لا أستطيع أن أعرّف نفسي
كموظف تفاحة علنًا ، فقط
لا يجب أن أفعل ذلك في  بطريقة
تجعل الشركة تبدو سيئة